during each item please put your hand up
to indicate you wish to speak I will
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sounding sound recording is dependent on
the correct use of microphones therefore
can I ask you that when invited to speak
you remember to turn your microphone on
and turn it off when you're finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible
do we have any apologies for absenced uh
Miss bird
thank you item four to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary interests other vegetable
interests and non-regisible interests
related to items of business on the
agenda having read regard to paragraph 9
and appendix B of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are also required to disclose any
such interests as soon as they become
aware should the need arise through the
meeting do I have any Declarations of
interest
in the interest of openness and
transparency I am a personal license
holder and prior to that in fact holder
of justice is unlicensed
um and so yeah no that's it thank you
thank you
a gender item five it's an application
for a review of a premises license for
Malden King Kebab 159 High Street Malden
we moved to a gender item 5 found on
pages 5 to 44.
I refer anyone to the present present to
the aid Memoir found on page two of the
agenda pack which details the procedure
we will follow for this meeting please
could I firstly ask that everybody has
read the officer's report and appendices
and the evidence submitted which was
circulated prior to this meeting
yeah yes
lovely
all right
should anyone have any late
documentation in support of a rep of a
present type representation of the
application this that may only be
introduced with the consent of all
parties
I take it there is no
further
members and those present to advise and
confirm they have a riddle yeah we've
done that
Mara I may ask other persons present at
this meeting to introduce themselves
starting with the applicant Essex police
uh good morning Char uh my name is Rona
McManus I'm the senior licensing officer
for Essex police okay
good morning
I Chancellor moldum District licensing
officer okay thank you
good morning everyone I'm the principal
lead licensing officer for Chelmsford
city council and Malden District Council
thank you thank you
good morning I'm Emma Holmes I'm the
lead good morning my name is Gilligan
thank you
good morning everyone I'm Eunice Palace
I'm just here to translate for a man
thank you
thank you everybody now I call on Mr
winter the licensing officer to provide
a brief outline of the application Mr
Winter thank you chair I just wanted to
make one small clarification as to the
address of the Malden King Kebab which
is 169. I do apologize to I think you
said 159 that's just clarify for the
minutes thank you
the committee is requested to consider
an application to review a premises
license made by the Essex police under
section 51 of the licensing act 2003 and
to have regard to representations made
during the consultation period that
followed in line with the promotion of
the four licensing objectives prevention
of crime disorder Public Safety the
prevention of public nuisance and the
protection of children from harm
members are advised that they have the
following options when determining this
application
I can modify the conditions of the
license which includes adding new
conditions or any alteration or mission
of any existing condition for example by
reducing the hours of opening or by
requiring the door supervisor as at
particular times
so they can exclude a licenseable
activity from the scope of the license
for example to exclude the performance
of live music or playing of recorded
music where it is not within the
incidental life and recording music
exemption they can suspend a license for
a period not exceeding three months or
they can choose to revoke the license
so just a summary of the key issues
Malden King Kebab is a fast food
takeaway Outlet situated in modern High
streets
near to both commercial and residential
properties
the premises is licensed for late night
Refreshments only which allows for the
sales of hot food and drink after 11 pm
full details of the license activities
are detailed in the current license as
attached to this report
appendix a the original license was
first granted back in 2005 and has been
transferred several times over the years
the current premises license holder is
Mr Mehmet gilge who has held the license
for only a short period of time since
the 16th of March this year on the 20th
of April 2023 the licensing Authority
received an application for a review of
the premises license for Malden King
Kebab 169 High streets
made by sixth place in the grounds of
prevention of crime and disorder the
committee is also requested to consider
the application which is appendix B have
in regard to representations received in
the requirement to promote the four
licensing objectives
the grounds for review are that the
crime and disorder objective the
licensing act has been undermined in
that immigration compliance and
enforcement officers of the home office
discovered four disqualified persons
working illegally on the premises
the statutory crime prevention objective
in 2000 in the 2003 act includes the
prevention of immigration crime and the
prevention of illegal working in
licensed premises in particular
employing a person who is disqualified
from work by reason of their immigration
status is a criminal activity which
according to the home office guidance to
the licensing act 2003 should be treated
particularly seriously
the application has been made properly
in accordance to the license in act 2003
and all procedures quickly followed
a public notice was displayed on the
premises advertising the review after
the day following receipt of the
application and all responsible
authorities were notified of the
application the closing date for
representations with the 18th of May
this year on the 21st of April 2023 all
responsible authorities were notified of
the application for the review in the
premises of the premises license from
Malden King kebab and invited to make
representations should they choose to do
so on the 26th of April this year the
licensing Authority received two
supplementary evidence bundles from
Essex police to support their
application for the review this can be
viewed at appendix C of the report
on the 2nd of May 2003 the licensing
Authority received representation from
the home office full details um
are attached to as appendix d
um should they choose to look at those
um it should be noted that because there
are no license Bill activities for the
sales of alcohol by retail therefore
there is no requirement to have a
designated premises supervisor or the
DPS on the premises
so to conclude the relevant sections of
the state of the licensing policy are
brought to the attention the members and
are as follows where relevant
representations are made the council
will seek to make objective judgments as
to whether conditions may need to be
attached to the various authorizations
to secure promotional licensing
objectives
this application has been correctly
submitted at the conclusion of this
hearing members are advised to consider
the options as previously recommended
reports need to have regard to the
following six priorities which underpin
the council's vision for the district
supporting our communities enhancing and
connecting our place helping the economy
to thrive smarter finances A Greener
future and provide good quality services
and I won't read them out but members
are requested to refresh their memory on
the implications under the customers
equalities risks and resources
financially and humane thank you chair
that concludes my report
thank you
and councilor Thompson so I would like
to introduce those to everybody
um I moved to the applicant
um applicant would you like to make a
statement
thank you chair the case is relatively
straightforward as you've heard from Mr
winter on Sunday the 29th of January
this year immigration officers have
attended the premises and fined four
Turkish Nationals working illegally at
the premises two of these uh young men
they're all Turkish Nationals two of
them have entered illegally and had
appealed to remain which had been
refused the remaining two there was no
trace of them having entered the country
at all
the only other assumption to make is
that they've also entered the the
country illegally
um as you've identified this is not a an
alcohol license that we're looking for
revocation on this is a late night
refreshment only
um we would seek that
um
that the late night refreshment is
revoked entirely
um that's a balance that the premises
can still operate and and sort of
operate and create sort of support the
the staff that are there but also sends
a message that a legal working cannot be
tolerated
um
it uh the reason that it can't it that
we need to make a stand uh is because
people coming into this country
illegally have the have they have been
in the past uh been
working for no no no payment there's no
protection under the law for illegal
workers and as we found here that one of
the 19 year old males was being paired
in cigarettes
so there was no protection there's no
minimum wage there's there's no
protection for these individuals that
have come to our country
um at the time of the immigration
officers it must be noted that uh the
staff were met with uh hostile and
aggressive behavior which is evidenced
in their in the home office's statement
um
I I think that's really encapsulates
everything that Essex police would like
to say unless you've got any questions
um I will come to them in a minute yeah
so Mr gigil would you like to make an
opening statement
s
um yeah
can you put your mic on sorry with one
of the victims that has got caught with
a cigarette he's saying that um he must
what he's saying is he's not buying the
cigarette to him he's buying a cigarette
from himself
he's come to visit me that day it wasn't
something it was purpose still working
for me he's come to visit me
from back home
as he's lost his family members back
home as well because of the earthquake
that happened he's come to visit him
and then then
he's not one of my workers he's just
come to visit me for that period of
because of the earthquake
I'm still sorry for obviously having
someone in the premises that's legal and
looks like he was yes
he's just come to visit me as he's lost
his parents back home so I wanted to
come and say sorry to him and
see him if he's all right
okay
I will now
myself
Mr Roman sorry yeah thank you chair just
a point of clarification the gentleman
that was being paired by cigarettes
um in the report is offender one a 19
year old Turkish male he was wearing a
Malden King Kebab branded shirt and
found in the kitchen food preparation
area and he admitted to working at the
business and that on the day he was
arrested he had been bought brought to
work by the owner and was not paid in
money but in cigarettes and food thank
you
cancel it down
thank you thank you very much chairman
can I ask um how long have you owned or
run this shop please
three years
um and
are you aware that it is your legal
obligation to check the status of
anybody applying for a job to ensure
that they can legally work in the United
Kingdom
inal
um
foreign
there is a legal responsibility in this
country for business owners when
somebody applies for a job that they
check that that person is legally
entitled to work was he aware of this
and did he carry out those checks
um
he's saying I've got my own four
personal workers that's registered
that's working for me
I've got four employees in my company
that's working for me that's in the
business
he says I'll pay my Vats for them tax
for them I've got four employees that's
working for me that's in my premises
that shows up they're watching
conversation he's like I know I can't
make anyone work that's immigrant the up
search and obviously asking for the PO
um payslip number to add them to the
working hours and sell my accounts so
did he know
that the four people arrested were not
allowed to work in the United States
but that wasn't working for me
okay
that's as maybe
um and then could you ask why uh why he
obstructed the officers in their legal
Duty when they visited in January as an
aggressive yes
um in general is that the 31st of
January that's when the when when the
the home office uh border Force officers
raided the property it's alleged that he
was obstructive to one of the officers
and they had to remove themselves from
the premises
immigration ambassadors Amanda
um immigration attachments
sorry I'm getting Goosebumps he said he
lost his auntie he lost his Auntie's
husband he lost his little nephew is
that all of them coming on top of me
he's like when I have someone hold him
like that is that it was just a reaction
I shouldn't have done you know I've went
a bit aggressive then I should have sort
of take it a bit more calmly because I'm
sorry I didn't want it oh no don't Mr
window I've got one final question
um does does do you know what the
current national minimum wage is in the
United Kingdom for staff okay there now
that um
and it is 20.
thank you Mr winter
the third that was the 29th of January
it wasn't the 31st if that helps you at
all
that's something like that thank you
thank you
okay thank you very much I will now call
on Mr Gill gigiel to make a closing
statement to this Council so if you
would like to make a closing statement
basically summing up
um
he's saying all I could just ask for me
look is um don't take my late late night
license from me regarding this I've got
twenty thousand pound rent a year
and I've I've paid my Vats and my late
night is where I've made my most income
obviously
it's going to be subject to a
prosecution
in relation to what sir in relation to
the employment of illegal workers that
would be the immigration service that
would undertake that I I don't want to
second guess what that is
I don't want to say yes and it's not
okay that's UK border forces yes
thank you very much I'm now call on the
applicant Essex police to make a closing
statement
um thank you chair again you you've
heard from the premises
um the fact is that there were illegal
workers that are evidenced by border
Force immigration officers and
yeah the facts down for themselves I
don't think there's anything additional
that I need to say I think the facts are
that okay let's see thank you
does
saying um the day that when I received
the email of the immigration people has
been arrested the Mind promises it
writes a name that was not in the
premises
you say there's a name there that goes
right but I'm going to run huge that was
not in the premises by setting
okay
um
I'm gonna go back to Essex police to see
if you can
yes sir of course mom
I'm reading from the statement of the
immigration officer
and the details they have are
um forgive my pronunciation uh gogus was
a 23 year old male
Z was a 23 year old male
um
kermiskey
a 19 year old male
and so like we've mentioned
in here
and we've there is mention of a
a Ramen golgus yeah
um
and that's
inquiries with the environmental health
showed that a ram and gogos was working
at the premises
um
so it that Mr gogis might not have been
there at the time that immigration were
there but they've LinkedIn obviously
with environmental health and used that
data to establish
the fight can you make sure your mic's
on please oh sorry
um
send the people that was there that four
people was there to visit me
yep
um effer Dodge was not there if a rain
Ryan Dosh was not there so
yeah and the album rest just come to
visit me and just to see if I was all
right and just to say sorry for the
people that I've lost back in Turkey of
the earthquake
and the reason that he's gave them the
t-shirt is because they had nothing to
wear and he said the only clean clothes
that we've got is for my employees
that's with my label on it in my uniform
and the boys also but we can wear that
until we wash the other clothes he's
saying if the officers went into the
house that we stay in they would have
seen their clothes or hang up in the
washing next to the door waiting for it
to dry for them to re-change their
clothes
he's saying I've gave them jeans as well
gave them underwear socks obviously
they've you know
thank you
Mr
McManus in clarification appendix D
um it's the home office enforcement
appendix and it's your page 42 lists all
the people that they encountered yes
thank you
uh is the Mr Winters did you want to add
anything now you're happy
and Kai um in accordance with Point 12
um
of the eight member this meeting will
now close members will then discuss the
evidence and representation will be made
before reaching their decision
all parties will be notified of the
decision within five working days of
this hearing
members are reminded that the applicant
and or person making representation in
relation to this matter May appeal the
decision in of the council to
magistrates Court
agenda item 6 closure of the meeting
members thank you for your contributions
this morning thank you Mr Winters Mr and
the Essex police I now draw this meeting
to close at 10 56.
um